[Music]  so i promise to destroy your world  in 10 days the galaxy needs its  guardians  who said this would be a relaxing  holiday  the summer of life today today that will  go down in history and thunder begins  today we'll fight  this is my vow oh god shrunk down  that may or may not be catastrophic for  the whole universe  thor love and thunder in theaters july  8th with pg-13 god's gone  get the popcorn out he's gonna do a  speech  see what's happening here  you're afraid  my friends  times like this we need to unite come  together  sorry me it's very hard to get a rousing  speech with the hate noise  oh god we're gonna die  so  this is my vow  oh god shall die  [Music]  [Applause]  marvel studios thor love and thunder  pg-13 tickets on sale now how exciting  [Music]  experience it only in theaters july 8.  [Music]  you